well we're starting with two stories
from Texas today and nothing really says
the Christmas spirit like Texas sending
buses of migrants to deathly cold
temperatures at Kamala Harris's house
and that's exactly what took place and
yet Texas has real problems to deal with
specifically the fact that they have
another Power emergency yeah this is not
a show from last year Texas having
another Power emergency for more or less
the exact same reasons that they have in
the past we're gonna get to that though
let's start with the migrant Story New
York Times reporting buses of migrants
arrive at Kamala Harris's home on
Christmas Eve about 130 migrants from
Texas were bussed to the vice
president's home on one of the coldest
Christmas Eve's on record in the
nation's capital this is a good article
by Stephanie Lai that explains
um what took place over a hundred
migrants around arrived near Kamala
Harris's home Saturday evening one of
the chilliest Christmas Eve's on record
volunteers anticipated three buses with
about 130 migrants to arrive in New York
on Christmas Day the buses were rerouted
to the Washington area because of road
closures and frigid conditions migrants
arrived in Washington after a 36-hour
journey
some with little more than a t-shirt or
a light blanket the mutual Aid group
helped coordinate travel and housing for
them provided food coats shoes other
warm articles temperatures plunged below
20 degrees the mutual Aid group said the
buses were set by the Texas division of
Emergency Management following the
directive of Governor Greg Abbott's
office I don't have to tell you whether
he's a democrat or a republican you know
from what he did quote they've been
doing this for a few months now it's all
for the spectacle the cruelty is the
point it's awful to use people in this
manner for political reasons
um we have video and uh as you will see
here
um folks arriving as you see some some
are wearing shorts quite literally
shorts the temperatures got below 20
degrees buses being unloaded and this is
a political stunt it is farcical it is
disgusting it's also dangerous it puts
people in danger because of the
temperatures we have another video here
as well you see the clock 10 p.m there
uh buses arriving people have been
handed blankets at least some of them
have but you do see folks very much
underdressed and it got very very cold
in the Northeast on Christmas Eve the
White House is a sailing Texas governor
Abbott per report from Reuters writing
the White House on Monday accused Texas
governor Greg Abbott of endangering
lives after busloads of migrants from
the Southwest border in Texas were
dropped near vice president Kamala
Harris's home in D.C
the Republican Abbott has not
acknowledged the drop and his office has
not claimed responsibility
um
yeah so what do we say these are people
who are prioritizing their own agendas
over the well-being and safety of others
and it's nothing short of disgusting and
absurd people's lives are being put at
risk people woefully uh unprepared for
the temperatures that slammed the
Northeast over the holiday weekend and
they're being used as political ponds so
number one we should recognize that
these are human beings they are looking
for safety they're looking for a better
life for themselves and their families
they don't come to the United States
willy-nilly remember many of them are
leaving families and the only homes that
they have known to take a risk and to
try to make a living now remember they
are both lazy and taking our jobs so
wait they're lazily taking all of our
jobs by working all of those stories are
completely pathetic and inconsistent we
know know that but these are people who
are making life-altering decisions to
try to better their circumstances and
there are folks like Texas Republicans
more than it's not even willing eager
to exploit them secondly when Governors
do this Abbott DeSantis Etc not only
does it fly in the face of basic human
compassion and decency it often actually
is misstating or misunderstanding the
legal status of many of these folks I
don't yet know the legal status of these
130 individuals oftentimes the term
migrant is used and then it's often
replaced with illegal immigrant but in a
prior busing stunt
where migrants were bussed to the north
they were folks who were actually that
they they requested Asylum and their
cases were being processed and they were
not actually here what we would Define
as illegally per the law per Asylum law
and so understand that very often it's
not even accurately making the very
deranged and inhuman point that they are
trying to make last thing
Americans are actually in agreement on
many aspects of the immigration debate
particularly DACA fewer six when you
were brought here by your undocumented
immigrant parents and from age 6 to 20
you grew up in the United States went to
school in the United States Etc
it would be insanely cruel and illogical
to send that individual who was six when
they came here and is now 20. back to
quote their country which isn't even
really their country anymore in fact I
came to the us legally when I was five
and legally or illegally my upbringing
my schooling my acculturization was in
the United States it had I been brought
here by my parents illegally at age five
to say when I was 20 in the middle of
college you've got to go back to
Argentina
would be extraordinarily inhumane
um and that is something that most
Americans agree with and yet we are
unable to make progress on that we've
talked about why there are political
factions at play and on and on and on
lastly
really lastly
these bussing stunts will probably have
unintended consequences and what I mean
by that is you send migrants to States
and sometimes they're not even told
until they arrive that this is happening
so it puts an additional strain on local
resources and it arguably exacerbates
difficult situations that the migrants
find themselves in okay so you're
irresponsibly and short-sightedly to get
headlines doing something which will
actually make the problem worse that
you're trying to solve because if the
migrants were able to stay or go to a
place that was actually prepared and
resourced to receive them
it would have a dramatically lower
impact on those communities nobody's
saying there is no impact when people
arrive in a community but by
deliberately choosing to willy-nilly at
10 pm bus folks to a place that isn't
even expecting them you're actually just
making the problem worse so this is what
Texas spent Christmas doing and
meanwhile look at what else is going on